hi my name is Ali tequila hi everyone my
name is Hannah no Akiyama I'm hito me
and i Maya so today we'll be reviewing
two kinds of cheap instant noodles chip
Nando's let me try it before yeah I feel
like I don't know being Japanese you
grow up on instant noodles that's right
that's like a quick snack cheap I eat
instant noodles a little more than I
liked I will admit I love the spicy ones
I am all about the Shelob young for me I
used to go out and then like drink and
they come back home with your friends
and the like eat like share a one cheap
noodle I do find that the ones with a
little oil packet in them tend to be a
little more tasty the more packets it
has inside there's just like it's
another yeah it's like another yeah
so this brand I've never heard of it
before
it's called nongshim yeah like that
classic instant noodle okay okay that's
dry head round it with a fork alright
let's do this alright
chicken chicken of flavor that's it also
is it usually like this curly no maybe
right it's using extra curly yeah okay
okay you do noodle M&E soup let's show
the show it's like no flavor oh how many
packets were in this one just wanna see
like that's how you know I'm pretty sure
this like the first song that you've
eaten like wrong and just like instant
noodles in general mm-hmm well the fork
I don't it's not good it's like a sponge
yeah got a noodle shape that's what yes
it's fun and just soaked up always
liquid I would not pick this one up
again no I love it
I also would not pick this one up
although I do like this brand I'm all
about no machine but not this one I
guess you're like so hungry and it's all
dying and there's nothing but in here in
shelf you'll take it they're really
relying on the corn for the flavor it's
like it's so bland
I know it's just there's no flavor and
heat yeah it's like I want more I want
that like I want to feel like I'm eating
a lot of sodium like yeah they're like
taking it so they want it coursing in my
veins
moving on yeah now have the mud itch
down instant noodles much the medic John
emerge this is like where it all started
I think I like the shrimp flavor when I
usually take out like the little tiny
shrimps cuz I'm not take them out yeah
those are my favorite part it's just
gonna throw them out and there's so many
flavors now - mm-hmm shining you like
the perfect bite oh god it's too much
that whatever is so America but this for
me of its flavor yeah I got it because I
think the soup - it's like if you were
to try the chicken like these cup
predominant and they're brought this
soap yeah so good even me is ie
3-dimensional you know it is so good
yeah you wouldn't like doubt like you
know maybe it's a real meat I know it's
none what color on this I think I like
this one more I think there's a little
bit more it's just like salt or whatever
it is just in general
yeah that's not bad I mean that's not
good I think American people eat like
beef chicken and a wild shrimp shrimp
will have shred the shrimp in light
flavor I thought that was this bad thing
I would probably go with like the shrimp
no that was like garbage probably yours
poach the shrimp which would you eat if
if the world was gonna end this one
probably this this one's the way to go
the mark my to channel one called
nongshim no no no no Jim
Oh yourself okay so Japanese granted
it's great really yeah okay
now you need that one ever again so
Japanese cup noodle or toxically good
they're so good so good so that's like
ramen
[Music]